hello everyone let's in civilized in the
world are on garriga's par for the next
few days I thought I'd show you another
game played by the man himself this was
played in 1977 so as far was I think 14
years old at the time this game was
played and his opponent guy West was 19
years old at the time and the guy West
became an international master some
years later but I don't know if he had
the title when this game was played
you can decide after you see the game as
part of his white and he plays efore we
have c5 the Sicilian defense Knight to
f3 nice Knight to f6 this time now
attacking that efore pawn so with a
Knight to c3 g6 d4 and now C captures on
d4 Knight captures on d4 and Bishop to
b4 and because power plays e5 attacking
that night
we have Knight to d5 and the power plays
Bishop to d2 and well Y can play instead
of this Bishop put the D to move a move
like Queen - Queen to g4 attacking this
g7 pawn and inviting blacks to capture
here on on c3 and if black doesn't know
this line he might play a move like
Knight captures on c3 and here we just
play a three and well if black doesn't
know this line he will have to calculate
and lose time and well it's doubtful if
you will find the best response which is
Bishop to f8 but after Knight d5
Kasparov played Bishop to d2 we have a
nice capture zone c3b captures on c3 and
now guy was played a move that could be
described as somewhat weird
he played Bishop to f8 and the whole
theme of this opening for white is the
weak in the dark squares around blacks
King so
Bishop 37 would have seemed like a more
reasonable move as the influence of the
bishop would be felt both on the King
side in the Queen side but okay he
decided to play Bishop f8 and casparo
went a Bishop to d3 we have d6
attacking that ePHI pawn and guitar
plays the Queen to d2 and here a guy was
plays a move and the blunders terribly
he plays Knight to d7 and this is also a
theme in most of Sicilian games these
are not one
block this the defense of the bishop and
c8 to this Aoife east six pawn so
naturally after Knight to d7 because
power played and Knight captures on e6
and kenderson I'd be captured well let's
see what happens if it's captured if s
captures only six then Queen h5 check we
have g6 Bishop captures on g6 with
checks H captures on g6 and alchemy
Beatrice and g6 only move is King t7 and
I'll simply Bishop to g5 check the King
has nowhere to go so the knight has to
block to Knight to f6 and now Bishop
captures on f6 would check and well like
is completely lost here after the King
moves the Queen the Queen will fall next
and what the game is over
so naturally after Kasparov played nice
casters and e6
his opponent decided not to capture with
the F pawn but well it doesn't really
matter what black plays he just lost his
eastex bone and he's completely lost but
he tries to Queen to b6
and this allows Kasparov to finish the
game in one move and okay I'll give you
a couple of seconds if you want to check
out the position and find it even pause
the video if you would like to in this
position well there are a lot of a lot
of a lot of moves that are good but
there is one move that ends the game
instantly and this is Knight to d7 check
and whatever black plays here is it's an
instant instant game over F if we're
example King to d8 and then simply
Knight casters on a8 and well black is
down a rook and this isn't playable and
if Queen captures the knight if Queen
captures on c7 then simply he captures
on d6
now checking the black King and also
attacking the Queen and c7 and after
this is defended either by trying to
give up the bishop or with King to the
edge and simply D captures on c7 and
well like was the Queen and this is over
so after night the c7 check his opponent
guy West who later probably in the
future became an international master
resigned so that's a very nice game and
this is a this is resigning in a move 12
so I guess because bar really enjoys
this move 12 I don't know if you've seen
the video I posted the workers power
sacrifices his Queen and move 12 also
also some people have enjoyed okay
that's it for this video I hope you
enjoyed this short game by the young
garry kasparov
usual you can check to my previous
videos here and thank you all for
watching i will see you soon